okay so I got this probably when I was
like 22 23 that's when I was like head
over heels with this guy I can't believe
I was dating him anyway I don't even
care haha What's Up G chimp it's the one
and only cash doll and I'm here to talk
about my ugly protector no one ever
asked me how many taxes do I have so let
me count 802 I know I got a tattoo on my
face as well I don't really get inspired
by others like they tattoos or ideas cuz
I really pay you that much attention to
even look at it that much or that long
to details like I think of like I've
seen a video of a GQ of someone else's
tattoo would be like oh that's sweet
that's a good idea
something but I'm just really my own
creator all my tattoos come from up here
I don't want to look like nobody
my first tattoo was my tattoo guys on
the back of my neck it's like a
butterfly and it has Beauty
I came up with that because I always
liked beauty Brian I love butterflies
because that's the beauty and
butterflies go together and I just
wanted that back of my neck I just felt
like whenever I have my hair up in a
ponytail and you know someone's seen the
tattoos then I turn around so she is
beautiful you know I hate it I got it
back when I was like 17 oh my god it
hurts so bad but it was addicted I'm
addicted to it like hurts so good
back then I always wanted to do what my
mom told me not to so you don't want me
to get a tattoo she was going off on me
or whatever I care I want to go get
another one in like two weeks after that
I was
now just like I should be like I told
you I told you nothing okay you did I
should have listened well I listened to
her them but it was just like little
stuff like that what you want to sleep
be with your friends your friends y'all
been bad and I just want to do stuff
that later on down the line you're not
gonna like anymore cuz I hate it I hate
I wish I can go back I wouldn't have not
once I love me now I'm just in the
process of covering up this one right
here was a rolls line but then I put the
feather right here so when I was like a
feather going all the way around the
rules mine I got that back when I was
probably like 20 to 1
it just wasn't cute I mean like over
time it faded a lot it just wasn't I was
just getting stuff I didn't even do my
research on the tattoo artists and none
of that I was just doing crazy stuff now
I mean the process of cleaning it up cuz
you know your body is art and I got
kinda [ __ ] up ring yeah her name is Ren
that's my girl that's my girl she's out
in Houston she hasn't wanted to shop she
covered up my last four catches so she
covered this one up right here I had a
boyfriend back in the day and we both
got our name when the shoes on each
other fingers I covered it up and put up
icing stumble right I'm a Pisces so this
is two fishes right here I all the cool
people fight you think about it means
Brianna pull my kimchi janae Steph Curry
we got the same birthday I feel like we
have like a great energy or fun we don't
hear you know free okay so my next taxi
let me talk about is this tattoo right
here I have to get this one redid I got
this back without probably like 1920
because my mom hated me in tattoo so I
got a tattoo hurt anyone it's a rose and
his brain drops going on a roll and it
has a name rain because my mom made me
drink yes I have it was really pretty to
me it just faded so I'm just redoing
this tattoo is a tattoo for me all my
life real Dave my friends like we caught
ourselves attack - Ian because we were
like the Bronski cute girls where the
curl is like the middle part bone
straight fly
we still is like
but number one eight girls in Detroit
don't ever do this with this is the type
of all of us had together
it's the bag of money like a money
symbols my best friend Kendra with the
Miss France for over a decade she has
hers on her shoulder
I haven't processed there like teeth but
she has one he's like I said it off you
know all the cash so this is like our
matching tats
we did all get them together my best
friend Kendra her dad so I might have to
upgrade because like I'm a different
quality of chick now so I can't have
this old but I'm gonna have to go over
there my next tattoo is I'll say like
this star and then I have it going on at
my side I got that tattoo when I first
started dancing cuz I knew I always get
started you know I just put it up theory
I'm just there I can know that I'm gonna
do stuff and before I was there I was
just thinking about doing art to my body
I was trying to be artsy this is the one
I hate the most because now when I have
long dresses and stuff it's just kind of
automatic crazy look so if you would
tattoo artists out there and you could
come up with a idea for me to cover this
up because I don't think I'm gonna be
able to move it send it to me cuz I need
it
okay so this tattoo right here was
originally a tattoo that was supposed to
be a naked angel but with butterfly
wings so this is the cover-up as you see
and it's not done because I have to go
back me and and color it over but this
is my favorite pen see this go over to
my shoulder too and it comes over to
right here but right now it's just like
I'm in my process I had like three
different sessions with that already the
girl Ren did this when it well my girl
and then you see the butterflies oh this
is getting covered up I used to say I
had 13 tattoos because each one was
myself but now that is all coming
together at this conference I had a
tattoo on my face it's over here it's a
start
cuz I just know I'll always be a star
yeah I have one of my ankle
it's a it's a tattoo that me and my
sisters and my mom house together okay
now it's just like a sister's keeper
daughter's mom you know iCarly a little
I love them we got it back probably back
in 2012 or something my mom had a we all
got it she was long that up later on I
was older she was Lina go ahead and we
all got that one together my mom has
tested she knows she just didn't want me
to do what she did and I did it that way
now I'm fixing them up I want to get
something on my neck now that I know
what I'm gonna be doing for the rest of
my life and I can do this I want to get
not like oh my neck right here but like
back here I want to get the number 314
and that's my birthday but it's also the
day that my dad died so I'm gonna get
that day put on me it's like that number
four
it's very special isn't it birthday is
November to 4 and then I'm dropping my
first album October to 4 so now I know
there must thinking process probably
different I know that you know I know I
have to wear dresses on carpets I know
that I have to go to these places so
they will look way better but since I
didn't I fix in my [ __ ] and they will be
cuter in you hose but I shut the [ __ ] up
cuz I know you I probably try to talk
[ __ ] cuz I want to get a fix and I'm
gonna be fine about it i mean i mean-
here is showing up oh yeah
[Music]